So, for the first strategy, picture
this. Imagine a coach in the locker
room. Their team's down. It's the
playoffs and morale is low. Everyone's
head's looking down. It doesn't look
good. But that coach decides, you know
what? I'm going to give an inspiring
speech. I'm going to rouse and motivate
the team to take action. What do you
picture? Do you picture the coach taking
out a crumpled piece of paper and with
shaky hands starting to read the speech
that they prepared? Definitely not. They
need to be able to communicate in the
moment. Not in their heads, but in the
moment. And the way you do that, the way
you ditch the script and get rid of the
notes is you have to get really good at
internalizing what you say. Now, that's
the key word. Not memorizing what you
say cuz that's linear. That's very weak.
As soon as you forget a phrase, ah, it's
like a chain gets broken. Internalize.
It's got to come from within. It's got
to come from the heart. You have to have
versatility and be able to adapt to the
present moment. So, how do you do that?
Well, what I found is that the accordion
method is the way to train your on
the-fly speaking skills. So, what is
that? It's really using time constraints
to improve your preparation process.
Most people give the same five minute
speech over and over and over again
until they wrote memorize it in their
head. In the accordion method, we say
take that 5-minut speech and then give
it in 2 and 1/2 minutes. Then give it in
a minute. Then try a 30-se secondond
version. And what you do is you notice
what you say every single time that you
constrain the amount of time you have.
And in doing so, you recognize, oh, I
know what's important now. If I only
have 30 seconds, here's my message. The
good news is that then you go back up
the accordion. Then you have the minute
version, the 2-minute version, the 5
minute version, maybe even stretch the
10-minute version. And what you're doing
is you're training this versatility.
Every time you do a rep, it's fresh.
It's spontaneous. And yet, you're still
getting the key messages across. The net
effect of all of this is you become
really good at speaking on the fly.
You're going to come across with this
natural authority. You're going to be
spontaneous. You're going to say things
in a fresh way, but you've also prepared
really thoroughly. So, you're going to
come across as a very clear thinker. And
by the way, if you want a step-by-step
breakdown of the accordion method, we
built this email course. It breaks it
down completely and thoroughly. It's
absolutely free. So, check out the
description below. Okay. So, the second
strategy that CEOs do all the time is
they're able to speak in a way that gets
people excited, that gets people feeling
a strong emotion. The truth is, it's
never been harder to hold people's
attention. And even in this YouTube
video, if I just started to speak in a
way that feels a little bit slower and
monotonous, then maybe you might tune
out because it's natural. We listen to
energy. We pick up on it. And that's why
it's so important to add a little bit of
that emotion and energy into your
speaking. And it doesn't have to be
super crazy, but it does have to feel
alive. And that's what CEOs do so well.
They speak with an aliveness, with an
energy. And you might be asking, well,
how do I do that for my product update
or for my scrum meeting? Like, I'm just
sharing data. It's not that interesting.
Well, there's a couple questions you
could ask yourself to make it
interesting. For example, you could ask
yourself, what matters here? What
matters here tells you, hey, what here
actually matters? And if you're finding
that it doesn't matter, maybe you're not
caring enough.
What if you really thought what matters
here? You might actually say, "You know
what? In this project update, my team
worked overtime. That matters here. I
want to emphasize that." And so, you
speak with emphasis. Or another question
you might ask yourself is, "How do I
want my audience to feel?" Because if
you want them to feel inspired, we have
to find a way to get ourselves inspired.
Or if you want them to feel blown away,
well, you have to feel blown away by
what you're sharing. The key point is
that you have to feel something if you
want your audience to feel something as
well. And you might say, "Well, there's
nothing interesting and I don't really
feel anything about this." Well, there's
your problem. Sometimes what we're
sharing is best left for an email or a
memo because the goal of speaking is not
just to get information across. It's to
share how we should feel about the
information and it's to communicate what
matters most about the information. And
so, even though it's been many, many
years since this has been said, I think
the quote still rings true. People will
forget most of what you said, but
they'll never forget how you made them
feel. So, the third and final strategy I
had to learn the hard way. It was back
when my co-founder Tristan and I were
participating in the World Championship
of Public Speaking, which yes, it's a
real thing. And it was the early rounds
and we were creating this speech
together. And Tristan had a really
inspiring message to share about facing
your fears and building courage. And I
remember in one of his first speech
contests, he was practicing in front of
an audience and everything was going
great except there was one small problem
which is that people were not feeling
inspired. Nobody wanted to take action.
Nobody felt compelled to face their
fears and we couldn't figure out why.
And it was at the end of that meeting
that an experienced Toastmaster named
Janine came up to us and she said,
"People don't listen to advice, but they
can't help but listen to stories." and
we're like, "Oh, of course storytelling.
Obviously, we all know this, but we
didn't apply it. Storytelling is what
brings your message to life." And when
we started putting in stories, we
started noticing that people couldn't
help but pay attention. And eventually,
Tristan got to the top 10 in the entire
world in public speaking because he used
and studied the skill of storytelling.
Now, I can't go into all of the
different ways that storytelling can
work, but what I can do is share one
thing that's really helped me in my
communication, and it's something that
you can apply into any meeting or
presentation that you do, and it's this.
Never be the hero of your own story.
Think about it. When there's a Star Wars
or Karate Kid, the hero of the story
isn't actually the main character.
They're more flawed in their ways. The
hero is actually the mentor, the Yoda,
the Mr. Miyagi. It's the person who's
more wise in giving advice. And the
reason that works is because people
don't actually want to learn from you.
They want to learn with you, alongside
you, like a peer. And so the next time
you want to change somebody's mind or
maybe give somebody advice, instead of
just giving it point blank, maybe say,
"Oh yeah, a friend shared this with me
that I thought was really helpful." Or
maybe say, "I saw this work at a
different company, my previous company,
and I thought I might suggest it here."
It's much more palatable when you're not
the hero of your story. So, the bottom
line is that storytelling matters. In
fact, it's the most authentic natural
form of communication that we know as a
species. Some people even say that it's
the reason that we've survived as a
species is because we've told stories
and passed on information from
generation to generation. So, if you
want to speak like a CEO, meaning if you
want to be a worldclass communicator,
you got to tell stories. So to recap,
three strategies. Number one, speak
without notes. Ditch the script and use
the accordion method to prepare. Number
two, feel what you say. Speak with
emotion, with energy. And number three,
tell stories. And when you do all that,
you have this way of capturing attention
and getting people inspired. And by the
way, there's a few speaking techniques I
didn't get to cover, but I cover them in
this video with Barack Obama and his
speaking tactics. So check that out.
Thanks for watching.